bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 18 novembre
confirme est confiné nous sommes
confinés nous le resterons avec une
adaptation au 1er décembre si la
situation sanitaire le permet précision
du porte parole du gouvernement la
veille du point presse hebdomadaire
d'olivier véran le président lui prendra
la parole la semaine prochaine pour
aborder la stratégie de déconfinement
progressive
les petits commerçants garde toujours
espoir d'ouvrir le haut karabagh vadimir
poutine estime que le cessez le feu
conclu il y a une
n 2 jours entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan pose les jalons d'une
normalisation durable même si le
problème du statut de ces temples
avaient pas réglé une réunion des trois
pays coprésidents du groupe de minsk a
lieu ce mercredi à moscou pour entamer
la négociation sur le statut du haut
karabagh vers davantage de contrôle du
parlement sur les exportations d'armes
deux députés en tout cas le préconisant
leur très attendu rapport d'information
objective se renforcer la légitimité de
cette politique publique aux yeux de
l'opinion
il défend des sept propositions
aujourd'hui devant la commission des
affaires étrangères de l'assemblée pour
eux la france est très en retard par
rapport à d'autres pays comme
l'allemagne l'italie ou les états unis
[Musique]
après presque trois semaines de
confinement certains signes
d'amélioration deviennent visibles
le gouvernement planche désormais sur la
stratégie de déconfinement une stratégie
dont on commence à voir les grands
contours quand un manque clair pour les
détails
après près de trois semaines à la maison
les français attendent la date du 1er
décembre pour être des confiné une
sortie de confinement qui devrait se
dérouler par paliers selon le premier
ministre jean castex plus vite et au
mieux la phase actuelle de confinement
produira ses effets en termes sanitaires
j'entends plus nous pourrons évoluer et
passer à une phase suivante mais mais la
cheffe de donnez pas votre question qui
ne sera pas le retour à l'entée
confinement c'est à dire que il y aura
des discussions de freinage sont en
cours de calage qui perdure au rang si
la prudence sera de mise lors de ce
retour progressif à la normale les
rassemblements devraient continuer à
être réglementé après le 1er décembre
ce sera également le cas pour mes
déplacements qui nécessiteront toujours
des attestations déjà exigé pendant le
confinement lors d'une conférence de
presse à la sortie du conseil des
ministres ce mercredi le porte-parole du
gouvernement a préféré parler d'une
adaptation de confinement plutôt que de
déconfinement il peut y avoir et c'est
ce qui est discuté en ce moment réfléchi
travaillé qu'ils pourraient être
annoncés le cas échéant une adaptation
du confinement à partir du 1er décembre
des jours qui l'entourent mais nous ne
sommes pas du tout aux déconfinement on
est même loin on parle d'une adaptation
éventuelle du confinement à partir du
1er décembre si la situation sanitaire
nous le permet parmi les mesures qui
pourraient être annoncées
la réouverture des commerces non
essentiels ces établissements pourraient
rouvrir avec un protocole sanitaire
renforcée
il en va de même pour les lieux de culte
et la reprise de l'activité sportive en
club pour les mineurs pour le secteur
culturel ainsi que tous les lieux
accueillant du public un nombre maximal
de personnes pourraient être imposées
mais à l'instar des stades où le retour
du public n'aura pas lieu avant 2021 les
salle de spectacle ou de cinéma
pourraient elles aussi être contrainte
d'attendre l'année prochaine enfin barzé
restaurant ne devrait pas voir
d'amélioration pour leur secteur le 1er
décembre prochain
ce n'est probablement qu'en 2021 que ces
établissements pourront également
rouvrir leurs portes
et comme des animaux et de restaurateurs
en france moi personnellement je me lève
tous les matins avec eux avec une boule
au ventre chose que je n'avais pas lors
du premier confinant on était encore eu
plein d'espoir sur une réouverture
possible assez rapide sur la possibilité
de battre ce qu vide rapidement
c'est plus cas aujourd'hui al'approche
de la saison hivernale
les français attendent de savoir s'ils
pourront se déplacer à plus de 100 km
lors des prochaines vacances scolaires
emmanuel macron s'adressera à eux la
semaine prochaine pour faire un point
sur la situation
c'est durant le premier confinement les
français rêvait du monde d'après ils
rêvent désormais du monde d'avant celui
où le virus n'existait pas alors qu'il
faut maintenant vivre avec faire avec et
se sûrement dans la durée alors question
commande est confiné des français pas
totalement confinés quelles sont les
perspectives les étapes place à notre
décryptage avec nos trois invités
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claudie ton dont un bernard président de
l'association france-dépression jacques
myard mer les républicains de maisons
laffitte et françois roudier
porte-parole du comité des constructeurs
français d'automobiles bonsoir à tous
les trois merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on parle
beaucoup on vient d'entendre dans ce
reportage aussi de la détresse des
petits commerçants mais il ya évidemment
d'autres pans entiers de l'industrie qui
sont en train d'être mis à dure épreuve
le tourisme notamment la restauration on
l'a vu l'aéronautique et françois
roudier et chiffres de l'automobile qui
sont tombés aujourd'hui le confinement a
été décidément fatale pour les
constructeurs les chiffres sont très
mauvais françois roudier
oui les chiffres sont très très mauvais
parce que il faut comprendre que notre
industrie travaille de concert avec le
commerce on va pas produire des voitures
qu'ils n'ont pas exempt du nid réparer
donc en fait on est vraiment dans le cas
typique où le confinement nous a frappés
lors du premier confinement est
maintenant une double x puisque de toute
façon nous avons pu livrer des voitures
à des clients qu'ils ont commandés mais
on peut pas maintenant faire le commerce
de ces voitures pour pouvoir relancer
les livraisons
donc on commence à avoir un véritable
problème au début du mois on était à peu
près sur un chiffre qui était positif
puis progressivement tout tombe
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que le
trou du premier confinement a
complètement détruit notre industrie
vous êtes maintenant en gros a quasiment
entre -25 et -30 % de ventes en moins en
france mais aussi comme on l'a annoncé
ce matin dans l'europe entière
c'est une industrie françois roudier qui
va pouvoir se relever de cet épisode
très difficile alors c'est complexe à
dire parce que notre industrie est là
une ramification très très profonde
alors bien sûr on voit les grands
industriels les français les renault et
psa mais lorsque vous descendez dans
toute la chaîne des petits fournisseurs
c'est là où on risque d'avoir de très
gros
problème avec des fournisseurs qui n'ont
plus de trésorerie et qui peuvent se
mettre en cessation de paiement est
fermé alors je serai peut-être des
grosses fermetures d'usinés des petits
paquets de 2 200 de 50 personnes
est ce que vous avez dans l'industrie
vous aurez la même chose dans le
commerce des concessions automobiles qui
va nous avons pu faire face à leurs
charges
ils seront forcés d'arrêter justement
une trentaine de présidents
d'organisations confessionnelles ont
adressé un cris des larmes au premier
ministre jean castex
aujourd'hui en plus à une lettre commune
dans lequel il réclame la réouverture
des commerces le 24 novembre il y a
clairement urgence et sont robin summer
jacquerie irene mia côté les
centres-villes où il y à des commerces
de proximité alimentaires continuent de
vivre et c'est le cas à maisons laffitte
et je le constate et également dans
d'autres villes
mais ce qui s'est passé c'est que la
liste des commerces essentiel a été
arrêtée d'une manière totalement
arbitraire sans définition véritablement
de ce qu'est un commerce est essentielle
et on n'a pas du tout compris
personne n'a compris qui pourrait avoir
par exemple sur un cordonnier quelque
chose qui est non essentiels donc on
voit bien aujourd'hui que il y a eu une
sorte d'habitude arbitraire qu'il ya eu
rupture d'égalité que ça c'est fait
parce qu'ils l'ont adoubée une liste
pondus par des technocrates un manque de
connaissance des proximités et jean veut
véritablement gouvernement parce que moi
j'ai pris un arrêté permettent aux
commerces non essentiels dit non
essentiels de rouvrir
j'ai constaté que bien évidemment il a
été suspendu par le tribunal
administratif
mais on voit bien que ça a été fait
d'une manière technocratique et ce n'est
pas acceptable
ce n'est pas acceptable ça monte un déni
de réalité
j'ajoute toute chose c'est que dans les
centre ville on nous a demandé de
manière sempiternelles qu'il fallait
muscler les centre-villes qu'il ne
fallait plus que ce soit des grandes
surfaces à l'extérieur des villes et
qu'il fallait animer les centres-villes
et pour cela on a mis en place des
politiques publiques qui coûtent parfois
assez cher avec les banques des
territoires etc
donc on a eu affaire à des prises de
position du gouvernement non réfléchie
et quand j'entends effectivement notre
ami parler de l'industrie il est clair
aujourd'hui que l'industrie il faut la
choyer
il faut lui permettre de deux tournées
15 et on voit très bien qu'en allemagne
c'est l'industrie beaucoup plus que les
services qui font vivre l'économie et
c'est cette industrie là que l'on doit
comporter et que l'on doit on doit lui
permettre de tourner et je ne suis pas
certain que le gouvernement en est pris
conscience même si on sait pas
pertinemment que il prend des mesures
sanitaires et je sais que dans les
entreprises
ils sont capables de le faire en tout
cas l'exécutif est sous pression à le
chef de fer va s'exprimer la semaine
prochaine tous clairement va le pouvoir
reprendre leurs activités
on a évoqué une possible réouverture de
tous à la semaine prochaine et qui ne
semble pas si acte et ont écouté les
précisions du porte parole du
gouvernement
il y à ce nouveau palier autour du 1er
décembre qui fait l'objet de travaux
actuellement et un engagement du premier
ministre qui a été pris à ce que si la
situation sanitaire continue à
s'améliorer dans les proportions que
nous avons connues ces derniers jours
mais je rappelle que la situation reste
grave en france
si cette tendance se confirme et si un
protocole sanitaire est adoptée en
concertation avec les commerçants alors
cela pourra être envisagée c'est ce qu'a
dit le premier ministre sur ce point il
n'y a pas de décision qui a été prise à
ce stade
il ya des discussions par ailleurs qui
se poursuivre sous l'égide de bruno le
maire et de alain griset avec les
commerçants et d'ailleurs les échanges
que nous avons eus ce matin nous ont
permis de faire un point sur l'ensemble
des concertations qui sont menées
actuellement puisqu'elles sont
nombreuses mais pas de décision prise à
ce stade c'est c'est bien le problème un
nouveau protocole sanitaire
manifestement pas vraiment clair ça veut
dire que le premier protocole ne vaut
rien dans une
certaines mesures françois roudier
comment vous percevez des choses nous on
les perçoit assez mal parce que vous
savez déjà dans l'industrie automobile
et même genre dans toute l'industrie
les personnels sont habitués à respecter
des procédures parce que l'industrie ça
peut être dangereux que ce coupé on peut
avoir des accidents donc le respect des
procédures
que ce soit dans l'industrie ou dans le
commerce automobile dans les concessions
dans les ateliers de réparation
c'est la vie tous les jours donc si vous
dites au personnel de suivre les
consignes ils le font et puis regardez
les concessions automobiles
on parle pas d'une petite boutique de
quatre mètres carrés une concession
automobile c'est toujours gants et vous
avez de la place qu'ont recevoir les
gens donc on peut très bien avoir des
systèmes où on n'est pas entassés les
uns sur les autres
nous le vrai problème que nous avons
c'est que après avoir livré sait très
bien ce qu'on appelle le click and
collect enfin après avoir livré
maintenant vous avez des clients qui
vont pas dépenser 15 mille 25000 euros
comme ça en cliquant sur leur ordinateur
ils veulent essayer la voiture
ils veulent voir discuter avec le
vendeur et là dessus on ne sait pas
comment faire sans avoir le contact
physique
vous avez des contrôles dans vos
concessions parce que voilà on m'a
souvent apporté que ce sont les agents
immobiliers ou dans les concessions
automobiles qu' il y avait peut-être un
petit peu deux poids deux mesures
beaucoup de contrôle alors qu'il ya des
dérogations dans certaines villes pour
plusieurs commerces là on se fait passer
pour des faux clients et derrière c'est
la sanction immédiate et des miliers
d'euros d'amendés de la part des
autorités
écoutez je vous dirais oui oui parce que
c'est quand même assez lamentable on a
une profession qui est en souffrance
terrible
vous avez des gens qui peuvent perdre
leur affaire des affaires familiales
dans les automobiles
vous avez des salariés qui sont sous une
pression absolument terrible d'abord ils
ont leur pression pour eux mêmes pour
leurs familles et en plus ils ont la
pression de leur boulot leur boulot qui
est pour eux essentielles vous savez que
dans l'automobile
c'est une véritable passion quand vous
rentrez dans une concession automobile
c'est rare que vous trouvez pas un
vendeur passionnés qui va vous montrer
comment la voiture fonctionne nous avait
même des voitures anciennes qui vous
rappellent l'identité de la marque et
tous ces gens là sont totalement frustré
alors si on va les flics et pour voir
que si la réparation essaye de dire à un
client mais vous pourrez peut-être
acheter mes cliques aimé regarder la
voiture non c'est lamentable je pense
que là il ya quand même un abus des
services de l'état qui est très très
néfaste à l'esprit d'entreprise en tout
cas tout cela crée beaucoup de
souffrance psychologique on en parle
peut être un petit peu moins mais c'est
l'envers du décor ce deuxième
confinement qui est en plus de l'hiver
les et trax dans la population écoute et
jérôme seulement le directeur de la
santé à ce propos santé publique france
révèle aujourd'hui que la santé mentale
des français s'est de nouveau dégradée
entre fin septembre et début novembre
la crise sanitaire ducobu 19 a révélé la
vulnérabilité psychique de nombreux
français on observe ainsi une
augmentation importante des états
dépressifs
le nombre de personnes concernées a en
effet doublé entre fin septembre et
début novembre
cette hausse est observée dans
l'ensemble de la population mais s'avère
encore plus marquée chez des personnes
en situation financière très difficile
les personnes ayant des antécédents de
troubles psychologiques
les inactifs et les jeunes et je me
tourne vers vous au cloud bi ton nom
bernard un présidente de l'association
france dépression c'est ce que vous
constatez et
allemand avec votre association oui
bonjour donc effectivement on se rend
compte que ça touche surtout les
personnes les plus défavorisées et on va
encore plus s'enfoncer les comme si vous
veniez aussi des familles et familles
dans des petits appartements où les
parents ont perdu leur emploi ou un
emploi précaire
il ya cette peur cette peur de l'avenir
cette peur de plus que plus pouvoir
manger même donc on a beaucoup d'appels
téléphoniques de détresse et en plus on
n'a plus la possibilité non plus d'avoir
da par le contact téléphonique
on n'a plus la possibilité de rencontrer
des personnes
donc on n'a plus d'activités de groupes
de parole qui nous permettait d'échanger
vraiment avec les personnes
donc ça ça devient dramatique donc nous
à notre niveau on a mis en place un
numéro de téléphone que quand même donné
c'est le 07 84 96 88 28 avec des
écoutants parce que souvent aussi
d'isolement sacré beaucoup d'isolement
les personnes seules qui ne voient plus
plus d'autres personnes
ce musellement est encore bien plus
important en ce moment sacré vraiment un
gros problème si jacques myard c'est
sont également les remontées de vos
administrés
ce moral en baisse on a vu le nombre
d'anxiolytiques qui qui augmentait
considérablement ses dépressions on l'a
dit on l'a entendu de la bouche de
jerôme seine au mont c'est extrêmement
inquiétant vous le ressentez sur vos
terres que nous ressentons c'est le
ras-le-bol ça c'est évident et c'est
surtout aussi malheureusement face aux
décisions du gouvernement
une certaine incompréhension je ne sais
pas si vous avez vu cet après midi ou ce
soir sur des chaînes de télévision qu' à
l'évidence la la pandémie en train de
tomber et que ça a commencé avant même
avant même leur confinement et donc ça
ça risque d'être mortel et parce que ça
démontre que le gouvernement navigue à
vue
alors ça peut se comprendre naviguer à
vue c'est jamais évident de prédire
l'avenir mais ce qui est certain c'est
ça qui mine qui minent le moral des
français
c'est un l'incompréhension des mesures
du gouvernement de l'absence de sortie
du confinement de manière rationnelle
intelligente et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons mis en place et que
nous mettons actuellement en place dans
notre ville une sorte de brigade
citoyenne pour aller à la rencontre des
personnes isolées
c'est très important avec des
permanences téléphoniques
c'est très important de le faire parce
que c'est je crois la où il va y avoir
de plus de problème je vais vous dire
franchement je suis convaincu que
l'industrie repartira il va y avoir une
mauvaise passe il rassemble des
faillites d'entreprises mais
malheureusement on l'a vu encore lorsque
un certain nombre de personnes sont à
bout et arrive à commettre l'acte et
dont on ne revient pas et qui ce qu'il
se suicide
ça c'est tellement grave et je pense que
c'est sur ce point qui peut agir et nous
les maires on est allé coûte bien
évidemment de nos concitoyens et je
dirais je dirai au gouvernement il est
normal que vous mettiez en garde les
français mais ne les emmerder pas ne les
emmerder pas avec des cons
le permanent 1 il ya un moment
ras-le-bol et la table pour faire très
attention parce que on rit qu'est ce que
d'avoir non seulement des faillites
individuelles c'est à dire des gens qui
me parlent peuvent se suicider mais on
risque surtout aussi d'avoir une une
révolte complète
déjà que ce gouvernement a une intrigue
ibilité féroce il n'a plus aucune
crédibilité mais si ça continue il vient
d'avoir un rejet parfois violents donc
j'en ai parlé par exemple avec notre
commissaire de police
ils font attention hein il rappelle les
règles mais on va pas aller emmerder les
français par des amendes en permanence
exane a pas de sens et c'est dangereux
on reviendra vers vous françois roudier
pour faire vous fait réagir aux propos
de jacques milliard mais justement
jacques myard qui a également évoqué
cette question est difficile du suicide
on a eu l'exemple en belgique
malheureusement on l'a appris qu'une
commerçante de 24 ans avait mis fin à
ses jours parce qu'elle venait d'ouvrir
son petit commerce et
et voilà est clairement les raisons sont
évoquées que cette faillite précoce a
entraîné son suicide justement que le
dit tonton bernard vous le craignez vous
dans votre association ce type de
situations à l'afflux des suicides en
france notamment à ben oui oui hein
il ya quand même en temps normal au
moins déjà 9000 suicide en france donc
là je pense que ça va être augmentée
documents et et puis de le mal être
aussi des personnes c'est de pas pouvoir
se projeter dans l'avenir
ils nous disent on ne peut pas faire de
projets donc on est mal on est mal
voilà on voudrait surtout aussi leur
dire de ne pas écouter les informations
en boucle parce que certaines personnes
qui sont devant leur télévision
toute la journée en train d'écouter des
informations qui souvent sont
contradictoires qui vraiment démolissent
le moral des gens la catastrophe cycle
françois roudier
claudie tendon ans bernard a mais voilà
le doigt sur quelque chose d'important
le manque de perspectives et surtout de
planification dans votre industrie
également
on imagine que c'est extrêmement
important de pouvoir planifier quelques
mois à l'avancé ce que vous naviguez
complètement a vu dans ce domaine où
vous avez quand même des pistes de la
part du gouvernement
alors on a eu un bon dialogue avec le
gouvernement sur les mesures sociales
sur des aides au maintien des aides tous
les véhicules électriques
et là-dessus il n'y a pas vraiment de
soucis et je crois que le discours le
dialogue est assez bon avec le
gouvernement sur ces sujets là bon on
regrette quand même quelques mesures
pseudo écologistes et qui sont plus du
quart bashing que de la réalité et de
préservation de l'environnement
mais le problème actuellement c'est
l'arrêt de la machine vous savez c'est
ce que je dis en fait l'automobile c'est
un client d'un côté vous avez la
production est au bout vous avez la
vente
si vous fermez un coin du tuyau on est
bloqué donc là il faut absolument
réouvrir tout ça parce que les
conséquences sociales commencent on a vu
par exemple que nos constructeurs ont
arrêté des équipes de nuit avec des
intérimaires qui avaient été
sélectionnés et qui sont partis donc on
voit que tous tous ces petits problèmes
s'accumulent et se sont pas des masses
énormes qui vont être touchés en
salariés mais petit petit problème par
petits problèmes vous allez avoir 100
salariés 500 en tout ils sont six à man
revient de personnes travaillent dans
l'économie dans l'homme dans
l'automobile rien qu'en france alors
quand vous prenez le l'industrie et les
services
on est à plus d'un million un million
sept cent mille personnes
et lorsque vous rajouter tout ce qui est
service transport
les routiers en particulier on arrive
quasiment 1 9% de la population active
qu'à un travail qui a lié à l'automobile
et de l'assureur qui va travailler sur
l'automobile il est lié à ce qui se
passe automobile actuellement l'assureur
qui assure sur l'automobile y'a pas il
n'y a pas de livraisons donc il ne fait
rien vous voyez c'est toute cette chaîne
qui va être difficile à redémarrer et il
faut absolument que les pouvoirs publics
prennent conscience que le respect des
conditions sanitaires se fait bien chez
nous jacques myard
qu'est ce que vous attendez du président
de la république avait la semaine
prochaine vous savez je veux dire une
chose
il devrait moins parler parce que à
force de parler ont gelé qu'est-ce qui
va redire on a vu un certain nombre de
conférences de presse notamment du
premier ministre après rodez dit mais
qu'est ce qu'il a voulu dire
donc je sais très simple il faut avoir
des indicateurs simples à l'évidence
aujourd'hui il semble je dis bien il
semble qu'ils ont un ralentissement du
virus il le gouvernement doit obtenir
compte et je crois que le président de
la république ne doit pas s'exprimer
toutes les semaines tous les quinze
jours comme il le fait en revanche il
est évident qu'on sait ce qui va se
passer sur le plan je dirais politique
strictement je suis convaincu que les
commerces non essentiels vont sans doute
rouvrir si ce n'est à la fin du mois du
moins en début décembre
je suis également convaincu qu'on va
lever vers peut-être le 15 ou le 20
décembre
le confinement tel qu'on le pratique en
ayant un certain nombre de restrictions
et il est récent l'avait également qu
après les fêtes on revienne à un
confinement
parce que cette épidémie monde emmanuel
jacquemin vous nous remonter pas le
moral mais non mais il faut regarder les
choses telles qu'elles sont c'est pas la
peine quand on a vu à tout à l'heure le
porte parole du gouvernement a dit on à
une adaptation c'est un sac il faut s'en
tenir
mais je dirais il s'exprime trop souvent
c'est que c'est dans la durée que ça va
se passer
on sait très bien que toutes les
épidémies
ont une durée deux ans c'est ce qui
s'est passé à la grippe espagnole qui a
été tragiquement là on a peut-être un
vaccin jacques myard tout de même on
nous promet un vaccin
on nous promet vaccin efficace et
attendez attendez moi alors là je vous
dire je suis comme ça mathieu 1
on va regarder ce qui se passe j'espère
que ça va fonctionner j'espère qu'on en
aura assez mais pour l'instant
effectivement c'est le sait la lumière
au bout du tunnel
mais est ce que c'est un train qui vient
à face je le sais pas encore bon donc il
faut sur ce point précis garder raison
mais ce qui est certain c'est qu'on peut
prendre un certain nombre de mesures
dans le respect des règles sanitaires
qui permettent à nos concitoyens de
respirer un peu et de ne pas être
considérés comme des enfants celle ci
merci en tout cas tous les trois à merci
jacques myard merci françois roudier
merci également à claudie ton dont
bernard d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france merci à vous dans quelques
instants
restez avec nous nous parlerons du haut
karabagh une réunion des coprésidents du
groupe de minsk à se tient ce mercredi à
moscou avec notamment au menu des
discussions le statut du haut karabagh
et puis nous reviendrons sur les
exportations d'armes françaises de
député préconise de renforcer le rôle du
parlement sur leur contrôle
[Musique]
oga et sur la photo ici il était
surveillant au centre de traitement
nouveau destin il a été retrouvé mort
comme ça dans cette position un autre
gars a été retrouvé avec sa petite amie
dans leur appartement qu'il venait
d'obtenir blottis l'un contre l'autre
ils sont restés comme ça pendant trois
jours en lacets tous ces gens qui sont
sur ce mur sont morts prématurément à
cause de leur addiction
oui ils habitaient tous à akron akron
est connue comme la capitale de la
méthamphétamine de l'ohio c'est une
ville où le nombre de toxicomanes
continue d'augmenter chaque année je
suis arrivé ici à 14 ans et tout ce
temps ma famille était toxicomane dans
les années 90 et même plus tard les
médecins étaient encouragés et dans
certains cas inciter à prescrire trop de
médicaments des quantités suffisantes
pour mettre sous calmant un petit pays
quand j'entendais que des gens mouraient
hausse à doite de la bonne foi l'on
trouvait le type n'était qu'un fou ne
savait pas ce qu'il faisait
que ça n'était que le début ils partent
l'un après l'autre
le nombre de contaminés augmente chaque
semaine je pense que le système des chu
est à bout de souffle
si on ne réforme pas dans les prochaines
années les ch ur on va continuer notre
des plates le gouvernement ait
finalement pris entre deux feux il
s'agit d'éviter une crise économique et
en même temps d'hésiter à la propagation
du virus à jour et pas être à la place
du gouvernement français en ce moment
car hier que des mauvaises solutions
ce que des gens comme moi propose en ce
moment c'est que à la fin du confinement
on teste 60 millions de français
si on continue comme on fait là moi j'ai
un peu peur qu'on est coincé jusqu'à la
fin janvier
quand même
pato se donnant pas seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
à 20h30 heure française
soyez les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france on en vient la situation dans le
haut-karabagh sur le front diplomatique
le groupe de minsk se réunit aujourd'hui
à moscou pour évoquer le cessez le feu
dans cette région du sud caucase une fin
de conflit entre l'azerbaïdjan et
l'harmonie et l'arménie pardon signé
sous l'égide de la russie
la question du statut devrait être
abordée sur le terrain des unités de la
15e brigades sont arrivés c'était pas
dunkerque
la vidéo du convoi a été publié par le
ministère russe de la défense
au total à plus de 1900 militaires de la
paix participent à l'opération de ce
maintien de la paix dans la région
les unités du contingent russe de
maintien de la paix poursuivre leur
mission de surveillance et de contrôle
permanent du respect du cessez le feu
dans le haut-karabagh compte tenu de la
situation actuelle le commandement du
contingent russe a défini l'emplacement
et la composition des postes
d'observation dans la zone de
l'opération de maintien de la paix la
surveillance permanente de la situation
et le contrôle du respect du cessez le
feu sont assurés par les unités de
maintien de la paix sur 23 postes
d'observation
par ailleurs près de 1700 personnes sont
venues au karabagh via un couloir
humanitaire sécurisé par les forces
russes du maintien de la paix elles ont
confié leur soulagement écouté il n'ya
plus d'anxiété le ciel est calme nous
vivons tranquillement pour l'instant
nous sommes déjà rentrés chez nous nous
sommes très heureux que les soldats de
la paix soit arrivé merci beaucoup pour
ce last on est ravi et fier d'avoir de
tels amis qui nous aide qui ne nous
abandonne pas
si tout va bien nous sommes parlés a
tranquillement et nous sauve rentrer
tranquillement chez nous evans les
partisans du premier ministre mr maignan
nikol pashinian se sont réunis ce
mercredi soir sur la place de la
république alors que seize partis
d'opposition ont appelé à manifester
contre le premier ministre sur la place
de la liberté les partisans de nicolas
pashinian ont tenu à lui apporter leur
soutien pour qu'il ne démissionne pas
parmi eux plusieurs soldats revenus du
front qui se sont douces et dans la
foule et nikol pashinian contesté depuis
la signature du cessez-le-feu dans le
conflit du haut karabagh est ensuite
descendu à la rencontre de ces
supporters pour leur adresser un message
je savais qu'en arménie
il y aurait des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui viendraient sur cette
place si nécessaire
[Musique]
tout d'abord je tiens à exprimer ma
gratitude pour votre soutien mais d'un
autre côté
excusez moi je tiens à m'excuser je ne
suis pas venu aujourd'hui pour faire
seulement une déclaration
premièrement je suis reconnaissant je
m'incline devant ces jeunes qui sont
revenus du front
je m'incline devant vous devant votre
héroïsme
je m'incline devant tous ceux qui ont
péri je m'incline devant leurs parents
et je demande juste une chose une seule
[Musique]
convenons nous que vous resterez ici un
moment vous parlerez entre vous mais
vous rentrerez chez vous et pour en
parler nous sommes avec claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir taux de lenche
maison merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france la turquie soutient de
l'azerbaïdjan est à la fois artisan de
la paix est ce que c'est compatible va
bien elle est rien le juge et partie
dans cette affaire elle a soutenu
beaucoup l'azerbaïdjan dans son conflit
avec l'arménie lassitude à leur part du
discours extrêmement extrêmement
vigoureux extrêmement variées par
l'armement par aussi un soutien aux
talents terres d'état major des
officiers dans aller travailler avec les
tables d'état majeur azéri et les drones
ont fait aussi beaucoup de beaucoup
beaucoup de dégâts donc le laser badges
ont sans doute doit beaucoup dans cette
affaire au soutien au soutien du rck et
la turquie voudrait aujourd'hui
participer naturellement à l'opération
de maintien de la paix ne porte en lui
quand même là a dit qu' il n'était pas
question qu'il y ait des soldats turcs
sur la ligne de contrôle mais qu'en
revanche il pourrait y avoir des
officiels turcs dans la salle dans le
bâtiment de contrôle du cessez le feu
alors on en est un peu là aujourd'hui et
dans le fond le groupe de minsk qui se
tient en ce moment à moscou tombe bien
puisque ça permet à la russie de dire
mais le cadre vegas et le groupe de
minsk est un groupe établi par
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe et la turquie fait
partie d'ailleurs de ce groupe mais pas
de la coprésidence la présence et la
russie la france et les états unis donc
d'une certaine manière la turquie est un
peu remise à sa place pour ce qui est de
la gestion du du cessez-le-feu
paris appelle la russie à lever les
ambiguïtés lesquels exactement alors à
part la turquie évidemment d'autres
ambiguïté les deux mille soldats russes
ont commencé à prendre position
notamment pour assurer la sécurité la
liberté de circulation dans le corridor
de latchine qui assure la liaison entre
l'arménie et le leader unique à rabat et
les troupes russes dont prendre position
progressivement sur l'ensemble des
lignes de cessez le feu et dans
l'ensemble des sept districts de la zone
tampon qui avait été conquise par
l'arménie en 94 et qui vont être remis
sous le contrôle de l'azerbaïdjan au
front au fur et à mesure que les troupes
arméniennes se retire et bien les
troupes de maintien de la paix de la
russie pour s'installer et la question
qu'on se pose avec cet accord conclut
est ce la fin du conflit gelé au karam a
écouté peut-être au bout du compte parce
que sinon regardez attentivement le le
communiqué du 10 novembre l'accord donc
été conclu entre la russie l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan
on constate que comme je le disais à
l'instant la russie garantit la liberté
de circulation dans le corridor de
latchine regarde la cchit c'est le
cordon ombilical entre l'arménie et le
néo gothique à rabat et donc c'est une
garantie qui est donnée pour dix ans
probablement à l'arménie puisque ce
contingent de maintien de la paix est là
pour cinq ans renouvelables une fois
sauf
d'accord d'une des parties et puis il ya
un deuxième corridors et ça c'est une
nouveauté qui est instaurée entre la
province de nick hatch ivan qui
appartient à l'azerbaïdjan mais qui est
de l'autre côté de l'arménie et par
conséquent ce corridor qui reliera ce
territoire d'une katché vannes à
l'arménie va également être garanti la
liberté de circulation
il sera garanti par les gardes
frontières du fsb le fsb
c'est les services de sécurité interne à
la russie donc c'est tout à fait un
engagement très important et jusqu'à
présent lorsque les azéri voulait aller
aux likhacheva lille devait passer par
une route très compliqué très escarpée à
l'intérieur de l'iran et maintenant ils
pourront aller directement en passant
par le sud de l'arménie
c'est donc évidemment une concession
arménienne et c'est probablement
l'élément le plus important de l'accord
pour le développement économique de la
région
parce que cela veut dire que l'on pourra
aller directement de la mer caspienne à
la mer noire et que les turcs sont
évidemment sur ce passage à das beaucoup
d'importance à cela
est ce que ça veut dire que dans le fond
puisque les russes garantissent le le
couloir de la cchit le corridor de
latchine pour accéder au niveau du
karabakh est ce que ça veut dire que
pendant dix ans le nivernais karabakh ne
sera pas menacé et bien oui je le crois
il irait il revient maintenant au groupe
de minsk de décider de son statut est-ce
que s'il ya trois solutions ou bien on
le rattache carrément à l'arménie avec
ce couloir qui est le cordon ombilical
ou bien on en fait une région autonome
de l'azerbaïdjan ou bien on inhale et on
invente une peau souveraineté des deux
pays voisin sur le nagorny karabakh
selon lee grady karabakh
c'est une région montagneuse
où il y avait un conflit 150000
habitants c'est donc très peu de choses
sur le plan économique mais c'est une
région hautement symbolique pour un pays
comme pour l'eau merci beaucoup aux
codes blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales d'avoir apporté votre
éclairage les armes au coeur de
nouvelles révélations du site
d'information mediapart appartenant aux
émirats arabes unis utilisé contre des
civils libyens ces armes seraient
entretenus par des entreprises
françaises les explications et les
détails avec katia petrik la france
voudrait tels des armes qui in fine et
seraient utilisés contre des civils en
libye
un nouveau scandale dévoilé par le site
mediapart sème le doute sur la politique
française en la matière l'onu a voté un
embargo sur les ventes d'armes en libye
en 2011
et la france semble s'y tenir en 1990 la
france avait conclu de juteux contrats
d'avions mirage accompagnés de leurs
entretiens avec les émirats arabes unis
ces derniers soutiennent aujourd'hui le
maréchal khalifa haftar contre le
gouvernement de tripoli
reconnu par l'onu abou dhabi a engagé
ces dernières années ses avions de
combat dans le conflit et certains
auraient bombardé des civils en libye
il ya donc un client final les émirats
mais les armes sont bien française et
surtout la prestation d'entretien est
toujours actuellement assurée par la
france notamment par les sociétés thales
et dassault pour des centaines de
millions d'euros
matignon les a défendu expliquant que la
maintenance effectués sur le sol émirati
mais un avion c se déplace un rapport
secret de l'onu révèle des activités
suspectes deux mirage français sur des
bases militaires égyptiennes utilisé par
les emiratis à 80 km de la frontière
libyenne
mais ça me rappelle quelque chose vous
savez que la france ne vend pas d'armes
non plus aux belligérants au yémen mais
vous vous souvenez aussi que certaines
armes qu'elle a cédé aux émirats arabes
unis
encore heureux et à l'arabie saoudite ne
sont pas utilisées de manière offensive
sur le sol yéménite
mais si florence parly ministre des
armées elle avait affirmé en octobre
à ma connaissance les armes qui ont été
vendues récemment ne sont pas utilisés
contre les populations civiles malgré
les dénégations répétées de la ministre
une note de la direction du
renseignement militaire datant d'octobre
2010 8 a révélé l'ampleur réelle de la
commande
le pot-aux-roses avait été découvert par
les journalistes du site web
d'investigation français disclose cela
avait valu à florence parly une audition
par la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense du sénat au
sujet des ventes d'armes de la france
chacun sa punition cela avait aussi valu
aux enquêteurs de disclose d'être
entendu par la dgs i mais passons
question de droit est ce bien légal de
vendre ou d'entretenir du matériel
défensif mais potentiellement offensifs
lors d'un conflit visé par un embargo
sur les ventes d'armes
la réponse de benoît mur atcher
président de l' ong action sécurité
éthique républicaine sur l'embargo sur
la l'écriture même de de la résolution
il est demandé à ce que les états
prennent immédiatement les mesures
nécessaires dont quitté depuis 2011 pour
arrêter tout transfert directs ou
indirects
mais et c'est précisé également ainsi
que toute assistance technique ou
formation et toute aide financière ou
autre en rapport avec les activités
militaires ou la fourniture l'entretien
et l'utilisation de tout armement et
matériels connexes
est ce que on fait du déclaratif
uniquement et dans la pratique on s'en
fiche et on vend des armes à qui les
achète et on fait un maximum d'argent
mais on ne pense pas à ce qui pourrait
se passer après et aujourd'hui le
gouvernement français est incapable de
tenir une morale dans la question des
transfèrements mais laissons parler les
chiffres
la france a livré pour 1,3 milliard
d'euros de matériel de guerre à l'arabie
saoudite et pour 287 millions d'euros
aux émirats arabes unis en 2019
de tels chiffres justifierait bien de
faire passer les contrats de maintenance
militaire avec les émiratis pour de
simple mirage et c'est dans ce contexte
que deux députés a présenté ce matin un
rapport d'information très attendue sur
le contrôle des exportations françaises
d'armement objectif affiché faire en
sorte que le parlement est un droit de
regard sur les ventes d'armes
un contrôle parlement
réclamé par 14 ong qui dénoncent une
opacité française quand il s'agit de ses
ventes d'armes
elle reproche notamment la france de
vendre des armes à l'arabie saoudite et
aux émirats arabes unis deux états
engagés dans la guerre au yémen
qualifiée de pire crise humanitaire au
monde
écoutez à ce sujet les réactions de
parlementaires les ventes d'armes c'est
pas juste une question économique c'est
aussi une question politique parle qu'on
décide de vendre des armes à l'arabie
saoudite
c'est une question politique et je
trouverai bien que l'assemblée nationale
est en voie de conclure nous commençons
à bien placé pour savoir pour connaître
le prix du sang et pour savoir que ces
ventes d'armes
notre cote certainement plus cher quand
on a le dis donc je suis pour qu'il y
ait beaucoup plus de transparence sur ce
sujet et qu'on sache ok on va pour en
parler nous savons avec sébastien nadeau
député non inscrit de la 10e
circonscription de la haute garonne
bonsoir sébastien nadeau merci d'être
avec nous comment vous accueillez vous
ces préconisations de deux de vos
collègues
écoutez ce sont des bons sentiments mais
des rapports parlementaires des missions
parlementaires comme celle là il y en a
déjà eu en l'an 2000 par un député qui
avait fait quelque chose de grande
qualité qui s'appelait jean claude
sandrier on est vingt ans après rien n'a
avancé
donc la question qui se pose c'est que à
l'évidence il n'y a pas de contrôle
démocratique
il n'y a pas de contrôle parlementaire
et il y a une manière de se saisir de ce
contrôle c'est de passer par une
commission denquête à chaque fois qu'un
problème se pose donc le rapport
d'aujourd'hui qui finira peut-être dans
les longueurs des étagères du parlement
il y en a des milliers comme ça qu'ils
n'ont abouti à rien il est là et en même
temps on se demande s'il n'est pas là
une manoeuvre dilatoire dont le
gouvernement a pas mal l'habitude pour
dire il ya des problèmes ou yémen au
liban en libye par dont vous venez de le
dire
la question du haut-karabakh vous
parliez tout à l'heure
la france a exporté pour 190 millions
d'euros de matériel militaire en 2019
dans le même temps le canada pour
respecter le traité sur le commerce des
armes a suspendu les ventes à
l'azerbaïdjan
donc la question qui se pose c'est que
le parlement qui a une c'est
constitutionnel qui a une fonction de
contrôle du gouvernement ne fait rien
actuellement rien du tout sur le
contrôle parlementaire sur les armes on
a des problèmes qu'ils soient
extrêmement fort pourquoi parce que
vendent des armes qui finissent sur les
civils où il amène il faut pas oublier
que les attentats qui se produisent en
france ils sont organisés par exemple
par des déliés minit et des gens qui
n'ont plus rien à perdre et qui savent
qu'un pays vende les armes qui finissent
par tuer leurs enfants leurs frères
leurs soeurs leurs cousins leurs
familles
on entretient un risque de terrorisme
par la suite
et j'entendais jean lassalle tout à leur
dire que certains cookies et peut-être
beaucoup plus fort que ce qu'on pense
que de vendre des armes dans des pays où
on devrait pas le faire parce que le
droit international nous interdit
actuellement de vendre des armes à
l'arabie saoudite et aux émirats arabes
unis qui sont partis dans la guerre au
yémen
jean tenait tout à l'heure dans après
ces présentations vous disiez que la
france ne vend pas des armes aux
belligérants du conflit au yémen
mais si bien sûr que si l'arabie
saoudite et les émirats envoient des
missiles et tuent des populations
civiles de manière totalement anormal et
on n'agit pas le gouvernement ne dit pas
il faut suspendre alors qu'ils devraient
le faire
et le parlement ne dit strictement rien
donc le rapport du jour je dirais c'est
un épiphénomène
on disait vous avez peut-être mal
compris de 2 est on disait précisément
que la france un vent des des armes à
l'arabie saoudite et aux émirats arabes
unis
dans ces deux états engagés dans la
guerre ou au yémen le rapport près de
180 audition affirmant que la france de
ce moment est très en retard et vous
venez de décrire il ya déjà eu une
première tentative il ya 20 ans
fructueuse l'italie l'allemagne la suède
sont beaucoup plus en avance les états
unis avec le contrôle du congrès comment
vous expliquer si j'ose dire si c'en est
une c'est une double question là entre
guillemets mauvaise volonté de la france
peut-être parce que c'est l'un des
principaux pays vendeurs d'armes c'est
quand même une manne de 8,3 milliards
d'euros voilà de bénéfices pour la
france ceci expliquerait cela seul selon
vous non non non
le leu leu fêté que pour moi ce qui ce
dont il est question c'est une erreur
stratégique majeure de la france pour
quelles raisons la vente la vente
d'armes a été assez forte dans les
dernières années c'est parce que des
pays comme l'égypte notamment à travers
le fait d'acheter des armes à la france
acheter également la caution d'armes
d'un pays
le pays des droits de l'homme donc il y
avait une caution morale en même temps
que l'achat d'armes
or on est devenus eux et à travers le
yémen
à travers ce qu'on continue de vendre à
l'egypte qui sert contre les populations
civiles
il ya des vraies questions sur les
ventes qu'on a effectués vers
l'azerbaïdjan et j'en passe
et donc on est devenu un état aussi
voyous que les autres en matière de
respect du droit international parce
qu'un droit international de la guerre
il ya un droit international humanitaire
donc on prend une très mauvaise
orientation parce que un très court
terme maintenant on va plus à voir on va
plus avoir les marchés on va plus
remporté les marchés parce que pour un
petit peu moins cher on trouvera
l'équivalent ailleurs
et on viendra plus acheter la caution
morale française puisqu'il n'en a plus
du tout donc pour moi le problème est
qu'on fait une erreur stratégique
y compris si on souhaite développer de
manière forte
l'économie autour de la vente de
matériels militaires
donc on à faux sur tous les plans
clairement y at il un déni de
responsabilité de la part d'un état et
des industriels dans le domaine de
l'armement écouter les industriels tant
que temps que l'état cautionne je veux
dire sont pas directement responsabilité
on a tenté de mettre en place des textes
pour qu'il ait une responsabilité
sociale des multinationales à l'étranger
ça n'a pas abouti pour l'instant donc
ils diraient les industriels eux jouent
leur carte industrielle points le
problème est complètement au niveau du
gouvernement qui est à la fois dans une
mauvaise stratégie
commercialement parlant est à la fois
qui entame complètement l'image qu'on
pouvait avoir à l'étranger d'un pays des
droits de l'homme d'un pays à au respect
du droit humanitaire
donc voila moi ce que je trouve
déplorable c'est qu'on est perdant sur
tous les tableaux
et pendant ce temps là on a mis plus de
deux ans pour faire un rapport sur sur
les exportations d'armes dont on pouvait
déjà écrire le tout le scénario il y a
deux ans donc il n'y avait pas besoin de
toutes ces consultations parce qu'elle
avait déjà été fait donc là moi ce que
je vois dans ce rapport c'est une
manoeuvre dilatoire pour faire gagner du
temps et que finalement il se passe rien
en termes de contrôle réel au parlement
avant la fin de la mandature et on
renvoie ça encore à une prochaine
mandature et c'est donc vraiment je
pense que ce n'est absolument pas
satisfaisant et 13 inquiétant du point
de vue démocratique merci beaucoup
sébastien nadeau dpt d'inscrits de la 10
ème circonscription de la haute garonne
merci restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de la crise
sanitaire la france qui encore loin du
déconfinement averti un porte-parole du
gouvernement en gabriel attal nouveau
point presse hebdomadaire du ministre de
la santé olivier ferrand prévue demain
18h et puis nous reviendrons sur la 5g
si son lancement officiel et bien
aujourd'hui dans les faits il faudra
faudra encore patienter pour son
déploiement
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
qui était assez violente d'ailleurs
entre les russes et les américains alors
que j'étais destinée à voler avec les
russes mais une opportunité s'est
ouverte de faire partie du deuxième
groupe d'astronautes européens du mans
voyez aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles à en est quand même
dans une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de nos terres
[Musique]
le nombre de contaminés augmente chaque
semaine je pense que le système des chu
est à bout de souffle
si on ne réforme pas dans les prochaines
années les six injures on va continuer
notre des plaques le gouvernement ait
finalement pris entre deux feux il
s'agit là d'éviter une crise économique
et en même temps d'hésiter à la
propagation du virus à jour et pas être
à la place du gouvernement français en
ce moment car hier que des mauvaises
solutions
ce que des gens comme moi propose en ce
moment c'est que à la fin du confinement
on teste 60 millions de français
si on continue comme on sait la moi j'ai
un peu peur qu'on est coincé jusqu'à la
fin janvier
[Musique]
on l'a vu un depuis le continent en
france amazon est sous le feu des
critiques accusée notamment de
concurrence est déloyale quand on
interdit tous les commerces de
fonctionner faut pas s'étonner que les
gens se tournent vers amazon d'asus
craint d'autres il serait aussi en
position dominante en décembre l'état
devrait prélever à 3% du chiffre
d'affaires réalisé en france
aujourd'hui on sait on sait très bien
que ça va être très compliqué
d'appliquer une taxe gaza à des géants
comme ça qu'ils vont trouver le moyen de
passer au travers
y'a pas que rare qui a du mal à être
performante a bien posé par les comptes
des entreprises deviennent plus
puissante que des états ça pose un souci
sur la démocratie
[Musique]
il verra t-on équipements et le cas sera
un morceau en ligne et aux mosquées il
prendra ton âme qui et puis le festival
qui est il
[Musique]
avant il y avait trois chaman maintenant
ils sont beaucoup les pèlerins ceux qui
sont venus pour un service de prières
par là
oh
[Musique]
longuet sur la photo ici
il était surveillant au centre de
traitement nouveau destin il a été
retrouvé mort comme ça dans cette
position un autre gars a été retrouvé
avec sa petite amie dans leur
appartement qu'il venait d'obtenir
blottis l'un contre l'autre
ils sont restés comme ça pendant trois
jours en lacets pressoir tous ces gens
qui sont sur ce mur sont morts
prématurément à cause de leur addiction
oui ils habitaient tous à akron akron
est connue comme la capitale de la
méthamphétamine de l'ohio c'est une
ville où le nombre de toxicomanes
continue d'augmenter chaque année je
suis arrivé ici à 14 ans et tous dans ma
famille était toxicomane dans les années
90 et même plus tard les médecins
étaient encouragés et dans certains cas
inciter à prescrire trop de médicaments
des quantités suffisantes pour mettre
sous calmant un petit pays
quand j'entendais que des gens mouraient
hausse à doite de la bonne voie l'on
trouvait le type n'était qu'un fou ne
sais pas ce qu'il faisait
que ça n'était que le début ils partent
l'un après l'autre la planète terre dans
un futur proche
liemandt qasmi si un débris spatial aux
dalles f3 coates touche un satellite
d'un pays cela pourrait engendrer un
conflit autour de la terre l'espace est
polluée il dérive en orbite
d'innombrables débris des millions de
fragments de tailles variées
incontrôlable qui est extrêmement
difficile de les suivre tous
heureusement les accidents vont se
multiplier les vols habités et risque de
devenir trop dangereux et les
communications par satellite vont se
détériorer les systèmes de navigation
gps pourrait devenir de moins en moins
fiables internet auquel nous sommes tous
tellement habitués pourrait
dysfonctionné et perdre en vitesse nous
gadget préféré le confort de la haute
technologie
tout cela pourrait devenir totalement
inutilisable
comme ses deux autres pas seulement le
cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout opposait se
sont forgées de la destinée commune dans
une perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vie des idées
courageuse des mots qui compte à peine
en soir vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche plus
extrêmes tous les témoins de notre
époque sont dans la grande interwiew
[Musique]
21h heure française merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mercredi 18 novembre
[Musique]
confiné nous sommes confinés nous le
resterons avec une adaptation au 1er
décembre aussi la situation sanitaire le
permet précision du porte parole du
gouvernement la veille du point presse
hebdomadaire d'olivier ferrand et le
président lui prendra la parole la
semaine prochaine pour aborder la
stratégie de déconfinement progressive
les petits commerçants garde toujours
l'espoir d'ouvrir un lancement officiel
mais encore théorique celui de la 5g
à partir d'aujourd'hui les opérateurs
téléphoniques disposent de leurs
fréquences respectives mais dans les
faits cette nouvelle génération de
réseaux mobiles sera visible sur les
téléphones qu'en décembre et que dans
neuf villes de france
la révolution technologique promise
soeur toutefois un climat de défiance
persistante
aux etats unis donald trump dimanche un
responsable de la sécurité des élections
christopher creps avait rejeté les
accusations de fraude électorale
dénoncée par le président sortant et ses
avocats le locataire de la maison
blanche qui persistent à contester sa
défaite à la présidentielle alors que
l'opposition démocrate appelle elle a
accéléré le processus de transition en
afghanistan la réduction du nombre de
soldats américains est une bonne avancée
réaction des talibans au lendemain de
l'annoncé du pentagone 2000 soldats
basés en afghanistan et s'en sont basés
en irak vont donc rentré en janvier 2021
elle même s'ils donnaient le train avait
dit que ce son est à noël président
avait promis de mettre un terme aux
guerres sans fin
[Musique]
les derniers chiffres du coronavirus en
france santé publique et un franc
énonçant 24 heures 25 mille cinq cent
six nouveaux cas confirmés par test pcr
et de 1877 cas confirmés par test
antigénique 427 personnes sont décédées
à l'hôpital ces dernières 24 heures en
forte hausse par rapport à mercredi
dernier le taux de positivité des tests
s'établit désormais à 16,2 pour cent et
la crise sanitaire avec un nouveau
conseil de défense aujourd'hui à
l'elysée suivi d'un conseil des
ministres
la france serait loin du des confinement
total selon le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent il peut y
avoir et c'est ce qui est discuté en ce
moment réfléchi travaillé qu'ils
pourraient être annoncés le cas échéant
une adaptation du confinement à partir
du 1er décembre des jours qui
l'entourent mais nous ne sommes pas du
tout aux déconfinement on est même loin
on parle d'une adaptation éventuelle du
confinement à partir du 1er décembre si
la situation sanitaire nous le permet je
crois avoir insisté dans mon
intervention liminaire et je leur fais
sur le fait que
nous n'avons pas gagné la bataille sur
le fait que relâcher nos efforts
aujourd'hui en ayant le sentiment ou en
donnant le sentiment que cette bataille
est derrière nous serait dangereux pour
la situation sanitaire de notre pays et
donc pour la sécurité des français
c'est le président qui doit donc
s'exprimer la semaine prochaine sur la
clinique alors quatre temps les français
de son discours je me propose dans
l'écouté quelques-uns j'espère de tout
coeur que le président va autoriser les
petits commerçants à réouvrir après ce
qu'ils ont vraiment besoin de nous pour
survivre j'espère que les fêtes de noël
auront bien lieu en dépit du confinement
on attend de savoir quand est ce qu'on
va rouvrir quoi correctement qu'on
puisse trop de gagner parce que bon mes
patrons il tire la gueule on se remet
encore un on parle on parle de fermeture
malgré toutes les aides malgré tout mais
il parle de fermeture quoi parce que il
n'ya plus d'argent corps déjà dans les
mesures à revoir il y aurait
certainement la sortie limitée 1 km
parce qu'on n'est pas dans la situation
du confinement du printemps il ya
beaucoup de voitures il ya beaucoup de
pollution et suivant l'endroit où on
habite moi j'habite pas loin d'un
périphérique et des commerces
en fait il n'ya pas vraiment l'endroit
où on peut faire un kilomètre en
vraiment respirant quoi je sais pas où
on va
je sais même pas s'il est assez où on va
ils le disent d'ailleurs eux mêmes
on sait pas où on va donc c'est au jour
le jour 300 ça change tout le temps
je suis dirigé vers ans et encore six
mois ne portait pas de masque
deux mois après on fait 135 pour avoir
pour avoir une amende si on porte pas de
masque on en a marre en fait qu'ils
ouvrent à un peu les restaurants les pas
forcément les bars mais au moins les
restaurants et que les gens respectent
en fait juste les gestes barrières parce
qu'on a plus de lui on a plus de villes
et quartiers sont éteints peut plus rien
faire et surtout pour la jeunesse en
fait la jeunesse je pense on prend un
coup
et pour parler justement de cette
détresse psychologique des français nous
sommes avec jean-paul miel et
psychiatres ancien chef de clinique à
l'hôpital sainte anne à paris
bonsoir jean paul miel et merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france
suspense à on nous dit pas de
déconfinement pour demain et si les
conditions de permet éventuellement oui
mais ce sera partiel on vient de le voir
le flou c'est très difficile à accepter
oui bonsoir tout d'abord mais oui votre
dernière un interviewé dans le micro
trottoir traduisait bien ce qui est un
facteur extrêmement pénible de ce
deuxième déconfinement c'est le flou
complet
on ne sait pas où on va et lors du
premier confinement on était dira
peut-être intérêts de renforts on avait
très peur mais on avait le sentiment
qu'il y avait lutte qu'on allait
remporter et que ce serait une question
de semaines de mois mais que y aurait
une fin là on voit plus très bien la fin
ça donne un doublement des dépressions
d'un mois à l'autre
des anxiolytiques une consommation
d'anxiolytiques qui a flambé également
vous le psychiatre évidemment vous
n'êtes pas étonné non pas du tout alors
mais je suis pas étonné depuis le début
je suis même étonnée d'une chose c'est
que dès le 1er confinement on avait
complètement omis toutes les
conséquences psychologiques et
psychiatriques il allait y avoir pour un
confinement est bon c'était pourtant une
évidence mais l'homme est un animal
social quand on le prive de tous et tous
ses contacts de toutes ces relations il
se hissa pauvres ils se dessèche et et
il peut tomber facilement dans un coin
sous de la dépression l' isolement c'est
quelque chose qui est très très mal
supporté alors je me suis toujours
étonné en regardant les écrans la queue
on voit toujours des filets des des
infectiologues des virologues entre par
l'auteur je ne savais pas qu'il en
existait au temps mais enfin bon c'est
j'aurais au moins appris ça mais par
contre je n'ai jamais vu un psychiatre
ou un psychologue sur les écrans or
c'est pourtant un problème qui à mon
avis est étaient considérables et depuis
le premier confinement alors
là on parle dédoublements dans ces
dernières semaines mais il y avait eu
des banques dès le mois de la vrine je
crois deux enquêtes l'une aux états unis
lui nullement en angleterre qui
démontrait que il y avait eu un
triplement des deux l'angoissent et de
la dépression des scores d'angoissé de
dépression est précisément chez les
jeunes vous voyez elle vient de parler
cette jeune fille l'a très bien c'est
que cette question là c'est surtout les
jeunes qui sont gênés eh bien c'était
celle ce triplement des scores se
retrouver chez les jeunes à peu près
jusqu'à 40 ans après 40 ans on avait des
chiffres qui étaient plus moyen est
alors au delà de 65 ans au contraire eh
bien c'était bien supporter cette
situation
alors là il ya un paradoxe ce virus qui
est en principe des violets d'un virus
qui menacent des vieillards de mon genre
il est très bien supporté par ceux qui
ont mon âge alors qu'il est extrêmement
mal supporté par les jeunes et donc la
croissance vous l'expliquer justement c
c'est toujours on en revient toujours la
même chose cette absence de perspectives
et puis peut-être que la jeunesse a plus
de mal à être contraint à ce qu'on me
prive tout simplement de sa liberté il y
à cela la jeunesse a besoin de bouger et
elle a du mal à ce qu'on la contraignent
un des deux patients est obligé
s'acheter un punching ball pour
supporter les semences ça vous donne une
idée
bon donc oui il faut la jeunesse ça se
développe en bougeant ça se développe
aussi en rencontrant des amis et pas
simplement d'une façon virtuelle
il faut des interactions entre jeunes
dans le dans le lycée la fac on se
construit à travers les autres c'est
comme ça qu'on façonne un peu son nom
son identité débutante
et puis la jeunesse elle a aussi besoin
de savoir où elle va
là elle a même plus où elle a des
examens dont elle voit plus très bien
exactement ce que à quoi ils répondent
et quant à son avenir
elle peut s'interroger sur ce qui peut
ce qui se passera même quand le virus
sras sera ré que comme la question du
lieu qui sera réglé autrement dit la
jeunesse là elle est brisé dans son élan
et les personnes de mon âge bon eh bien
c'est une épreuve à laquelle il ne
s'attendait pas mais ça ne va pas
remettre en cause leur construction
chan elle est de toute façon derrière
eux vous nous disiez voilà il n'y avait
pas beaucoup de psychiatres de psy sur
les plateaux télé beaucoup d'infections
longue bon sur rt je tiens à le préciser
on avait pas mal accordé d'importance
voilà au psy on en a eu quelques-uns
justement pour nous expliquer les
méfaits du confinement
la question est de savoir quand on vous
écoute est ce que le gouvernement lui il
a des psychiatres son fameux conseil
scientifique qui semblait et comptait
plus que personne lors du premier
confinement parce que on se demande si
le gouvernement tient compte justement
de cette détresse psychologique des
français dans sa stratégie face à la
crise sanitaire
écoutez je suis heureux que vous m'ayez
accueilli ce frère tu es bien que
maintenant soit tout soit devenue une
question d'idéologie et même votre chef
vous savez quelle est elle a une
réputation
contestant c'est ça n'est pas parce que
je partage des idées de l'un ou de
l'autre que je suis là mais il est vrai
que sur les écrans habituel on voit pas
tellement les psychiatres et ses regrets
tend alors à ma connaissance il n'y
aurait pas de psychiatres de
psychologues non plus dans le conseil de
dans le conseil des experts je crois
qu'il ya les anthropologues il ya même
quelqu'un qui je crois est une
historienne des sciences
mais je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y ait un
psychiatre ou un psychologue enfin il ya
peu de temps on avait encore pas alors
aujourd'hui si vous deviez conseiller
docteur le gouvernement sur les
prochaines marches à suivre puisque rien
ne semble clair définitivement vous lui
direz vous vous lui diriez quoi à
emmanuel macron justement en tant que
psychiatre parce qu'il faudra remonter
le moral des troupes un moment quand
même qu'il faut être clair d'une part
donc pas avoir des messages brouillés
qui se contredisent les uns les autres
et qu'il faut évidemment donner de
l'espoir en rappelant que ça c'est une
période difficile mais que cette période
difficile aura une fin et que bien sûr
c'est une période à laquelle beaucoup de
deux projets deviennent incertains mais
que tout sera fait pour qu'on puisse 'le
que la vie puisse reprendre son cours
même et surtout chez les plus jeunes
bon je crois que aussi il y aurait lieu
peut être d'abord des plus largement le
facteur humain non à part fait
essentiellement d'économies il semble
qu'à cette époque qu'on soit sensible
surtout une question de chiffres et pas
tellement aux yoshiro non sur notion
humaine donc l'ailé les chiffres
économiques et le nombre des morts et le
nombre de dd à désinfecter par le cos
vie ça on nous en parle régulièrement on
est abreuvé de données quantitatives
mais il faudrait peut-être penser aussi
un peu aux données humaines
merci en tout cas jean paul lemieux les
psychiatres ancien chef de clinique à
l'hôpital sainte-anne d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france
c'est aujourd'hui que la 5g arrive en
france et les opérateurs peuvent
théoriquement les meilleures ventes n
cinquième génération dans la journée
pourtant le démarrage prendra quelques
semaines et le déploiement massif
plusieurs années et pour cause il n'y a
pas encore d'installation d'antennes
suffisante certains élus s'ils sont même
fermement opposés on nous explique
pourquoi avec maxime hébert la france va
prendre le tournant de la 5g parce que
c'est le tournant de l'innovation et
j'entends beaucoup de voix qui s'élèvent
pour nous expliquer qu'il faudrait
relever la complexité des problèmes
contemporains en revenant à la lampe à
huile
je ne crois pas au modèle amish le
président emmanuel macron les a balayées
pourtant les arguments des opposants à
la 5g ne manquent pas
une des premières interrogations portent
sur les conséquences écologiques de ce
déploiement national conçu pour
permettre des débits 10 fois supérieurs
à ceux de la 4g sur les smartphones la
5g pourrait entraîner une consommation
d'énergie toujours plus forte plus le
réseau est rapide plus il va pousser les
utilisateurs à y recourir
et donc à consommer constat que partage
d'ailleurs l'un des quatre opérateurs
français la 5g permet lorsque l'on
transporte des données de le faire avec
moins d'énergie
en revanche elle augmente
considérablement les débits et permet
donc un usage beaucoup plus important
donc de transporter davantage de données
ce qui est beaucoup plus consommateurs
il est donc erroné d'affirmer que la 5g
permettra des efforts en matière
d'énergie énergivores le réseau du futur
et donc polluants selon la em la chance
pour l'économie et la maîtrise de
l'énergie
le déploiement de la 5g va
exponentiellement accélérer
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
non renouvelables
la pollution due à l'extraction des
métaux rares et la génération de
quantité de déchets pas ou peu
recyclables dans une tribune qu'ils ont
cosigné 70 élus de gauche dont
l'eurodéputé des verts yannick jadot
les maires de bordeaux et marseille ou
encore jean luc mélenchon mise en garde
contre le caractère polluant de ces
nouvelles pratiques
la fabrication des smartphones et autres
objets connectés représente 47 % de la
pollution générée par le numérique
un chiffre qu'il ferait qu'augmenter si
tous les français devaient se munir d'un
téléphone compatible
il y aura forcément une exposition plus
importante aux ondes électromagnétiques
puisqu'on va exploiter des bandes de
fréquences supplémentaires
c'est une autre grande question sans
réponse pour l'instant celle des effets
des antennes 5g sur la santé des
riverains lancé
l' agence nationale de sécurité
sanitaire de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail a rendu un
rapport en octobre 2019
elle constate un manque important voire
une absence de données relatives aux
effets biologiques et sanitaires
potentiels d'une exposition aux ondes de
la 5g
un rapport commandé par l'état et publié
en septembre dernier évoque lui
l'absence de consensus des agences
sanitaires nationales et internationales
sur d'éventuels effets néfastes alors
que les effets à long terme sont
difficiles à mettre en évidence
enfin outre la fracture numérique
redouté entre zones urbaines et rurales
le dernier grand débat soulevé par
l'arrivée de la 5g c'est celui sur
l'exploitation des données
ce nouveau réseau et la multiplication
des objets connectés vont entraîner plus
de transmission de données sur internet
le risque est donc accru de voir les
entreprises spécialisées capter encore
plus d'informations personnelles des
utilisateurs sans parler des
cybercriminels qui rôdent sur le web un
garde-fou existe néanmoins au niveau
européen
le règlement général sur la protection
des données personnelles ou rgp des aux
états européens et donc à la france de
jouer leur rôle pour protéger les
utilisateurs face aux géants du
numérique
et c'est donc officiellement le
lancement de la fin que j'ai sans perte
ni fracas et pour cause personne n'y a
encore accès dans les faits il faudra
attendre le mois de décembre pour
profiter de ce dispositif avec un
smartphone compatible un lancement qui
agace les maires en tout cas une
soixantaine d'élus demande un moratoire
et plaide pour je cite la tenue d'un
débat démocratique décentralisée elle
place un autre décryptage avec nos
invités et pour en parler nous sommes
avec ali j art experts numériques vous
êtes également ancien maire adjoint de
ce grand chargé à l'époque du
développement économique et numériques
bonsoir à vous ali gérard merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés cyril d'helmand
chercheur à l'institut thomas more
bonsoir à vous aussi merci d'être avec
nous donc une soixantaine de maires à on
le disait de députés qui partent en
guerre contre le déploiement de la 5g
pas d'étude d'impact climatique et
environnementale aucune concept aux
consultations publiques préalables sur
ce dossier vous comprenez tout de même
leurs inquiétudes et ligier à écouter en
fait je pense que concernant les
débouchés de la sagem on est tous
d'accord sur les fait une grosse avancée
technologique qui va permettre
effectivement des usages nouveaux et des
avancées importantes au niveau
industriel
par contre effectivement comme vous
l'avait annoncé dans votre reportage on
a des conséquences eurothermes de haut
niveau de la santé qui sont incertaines
l'organisent organisation mondiale de la
santé a elle même parle elle-même de
dangerosité par rapport aux ondes
électromagnétiques
et c'est vrai que concernant la 5g on
utilise en fait des ondes de haute
fréquence qui transportent plus
d'énergie que des ondes basses
fréquences et donc le rayonnement est
beaucoup plus important avec voilà des
conséquences incertaines sur les
molécules
c'est la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'un débat plus
plus clair sur ce sujet là de la santé
puisque effectivement on ne peut pas
accepter une innovation technologique au
détriment de la santé de nos
compatriotes alors parmi les maires qui
coince un sur la 5g
martine aubry à lille et connaît son
tweet regarder parce que nos doutes
persistent tant du point de vue
sanitaire que de la sobriété numérique
sur le déploiement de la 5g
nous avons voté au conseil municipal ce
soir un moratoire
il est urgent d'attendre il est urgent
d'attendre alors c'est vrai que c'est
pas la première fois qu'on évoque les
éventuels problèmes de santé publique si
lille d'helmand est ce qu'il y à des
études clair sur ce point parce que ça
reste le grand fou et c'est extrêmement
au béton bien évidemment des études
clair non manifestement il y en a pas il
ya plusieurs études fameux front
contradictoires il ya hlalef de l'om est
qu'en fermant l'électromagnétisme par
contre on aurait peut-être simplement à
regarder déjà l'impact ou de la 4g sur
les populations manifestement personne
aujourd'hui n'est capable de déterminer
qui a un impact négatif ou simon n'a pas
donc effectivement la fréquence des
ondes n'est pas la même mais aujourd'hui
personne et est en capacité et notamment
à long terme de dire s'il y aura des
impacts négatifs youphil y en a pas
c'est pour moi c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment le point le plus beau quand
actuellement alors on va vous demander
évidemment quel est le point le plus
bloquants pour vous mais quand même l
igr ça paraît incroyable on nous dit on
sait pas si c'est dangereux ou non
fabron voilà on va la lancer quand même
c'est comment ça peut arriver dans un
pays en l'occurrence comme la france
écoutez je crois que martine aubry a
demandé un moratoire sur sur le sujet et
que des élus s'inquiètent parce que les
élus sont responsables de la santé de
leurs de leurs concitoyens donc
effectivement c'est un sujet qu'il faut
entreprendre jeu le gouvernement est le
gouvernement laisse faire il ya le
lancement officiel aujourd'hui est ce
que ça vous semble normal à partir de
man
un doute sur la santé publique moi je
crois qu'il faut pas aller trop vite
vous savez l'innovation à nous tire vers
le haut elle nous tire vers de nouveaux
usagers vers des choses qui permettait
justement d'avancé mais je crois qu'il
faut pas aller trop vite et la santé on
le voit bien on est en pleine crise de
co lead on a des des commerçants qui
sont fermées des entreprises aujourd'hui
qu'ils ne sont pas ouvertes justement
par des à cause de problématiques de
santé
je crois que la santé on a bien vu
aujourd'hui avec la commune 19 que c'est
un enjeu absolument oui je de liaison
avec à les gia avant de rétablir la
liaison avec vous alliez jr je vous
propose d'écouter xavier niel 1 pour lui
on ne doit pas avoir peur de la scène
j'ai écouté la 5g ne doit pas faire peur
c'est une formidable opportunité pour
construire une société plus sobre plus
efficace avec une gestion de la ville
améliorer ce serait dommage en france
d'avoir les meilleurs réseaux fixes avec
les offres fibres les plus rapides
d'europe et d'être le dernier européen
sur le mobile
en refusant le marché de la 5g xavier
niel lui qui est rassurant
spécialiste de la deûle et la téléphonie
évidemment vous a nié saviez niel entre
autres choses
cyril d'allemands tout à l'heure j'ai
seulement que j'essayais c'est pas
forcément les questions de santé qui me
font le plus peur alors qu'est ce qui
vous fait le plus peur c'est là la force
de stratégie de déploiement
d'anticipation l'absence de stratégie
économique de plan économique par
rapport à la fin juin
on voit que les premières phases de test
cependant quand même temps cinq
métropoles alors que la 100g et quand
même vendu pour participer à au
désenclavement numérique
j'ai du mal à comprendre que dans le
cerveau de nos énarques il peut pas
aider pas émergé l'idée
de faire une phase de test sur une ville
moyenne ou petite ville aujourd'hui
n'est pas n'est pas fibrés ben c'est ça
c'est un point qui me semble quand même
majeurs d'autre part au niveau de mes
inquiétudes
c'est que vous n'avez aucun vendeur de
smartphones européen dans les 12
premiers vendeurs mondiaux de
smartphones vous avez bien sûr pas le
français il n'y a pas de stratégie pour
au niveau avant au niveau de l'industrie
française
en ce qui concerne les objets connectés
on a le problème des antennes on n'a
toujours pas réglé le problème de you et
enfin on a l'impression en fait de la
cavalerie polonaise qui cherchent des
blancs des allemands on repart avec rien
et on va lancer une technologie un qui
est effectivement très prometteuse et
qui pourrait être une source de
développement d'industries françaises
mais qui risque de devenir en fait le
point d'entrée et de développement de
toutes les entreprises étrangères et les
entreprises françaises et européennes
vont rester sur le bas côté
donc c'est ça m'inquiète beaucoup plus
que de potentialités de potentiel pardon
danger sur la santé qui aujourd'hui ne
sont absolument pas avéré
si on utilise cette rhétorique en fait
le moteur inclusion ans l'aurait jamais
développé ces polluants ça peut générer
des problèmes de santé ces produits des
particules fines bon heureusement je
dirais qu'on a développé le moteur à
explosion
donc pour moi le problème n'est pas sur
cet aspect de santé après faire des
moratoires sur tout ce qui à tout ce qui
peut poser un problème en partant du
principe de précaution
eh bien on voit ce que ça peut donner
dans la gestion de la crise sanitaire et
l'hygiène c'était intéressant cet
argumentaire de cyril
la porte d'entrée pour les entreprises
étrangères alors que la france
finalement restauré sur le bas-côté vous
partagez ce diagnostic et cette crainte
oui je partage ce diagnostic c'est vrai
qu'on parle de souveraineté nationale et
que le débat de la 5g ne doit pas se
limiter essentiellement à un choix entre
des technologies chinoises il faut le
dire ou des technologies américaines et
est malheureusement c'est qu'ils c'est
ce qui risque de se passer on le voit
aujourd'hui dans les pays on l'a vu en
italie par exemple des partenariats qui
sont faits entre justement les
opérateurs et les fournisseurs de
matériel chinois on voit effectivement
que on va on va vers ce verset vers
cette destinée par contre mon inquiétude
également donc on parlait de la santé
mais également là c'est la question de
l'énergie et de la transition
énergétique
vous savez le numérique aujourd'hui
c'est 4 % de la consommation électrique
mondiale pour comparer un petit peu
l'aviation qui consomment beaucoup
d'énergie c'est 3% avec 7,5 g et votre
reportage l'a dit on va démultiplier la
consommation énergétique
on va à des as des as des as des
montants absolument incroyable cette
consommation va augmenter de 25% au
niveau mondial et donc effectivement ça
pose la question de l'écologie et de la
transition énergétique
ensuite il faut pas je pense limiter ce
débat entre la liberté ceux qui sont
pour et ceux qui sont contre la 5g je
crois qu'il faut trouver un juste
équilibre et je rejoins votre votre
intervenant sur effectivement qui
explique cette avancée de la 5g sur un
certain nombre de sujets notamment sur
la création d'emplois sur des débouchés
d'autres débouchés sur leila la question
des objets connectés la question de
l'auto de l'automobile qui sera autonome
mais on ne devra pas encore une fois
faire toutes ces avancées au détriment
de la santé
il ne faut pas aller plus vite que la
musique aujourd'hui encore une fois on
se rend compte que nous sommes dans une
crise sanitaire cette crise sanitaire a
mis en branle notre économie il ne
faudrait pas que ça que j'ai justement
eu des conséquences importantes sur la
santé je pense qu'il faut attendre et
être sûrs que ce que cette technologique
innovante et qui est assez exceptionnel
puisque nous permettre d'avancer très
vite
cyril d'helmand le mode de la fin pour
vous par à quoi on continue un grand
débat sera nécessaire selon vous non je
pense pas du tout à un grand débat
nécessaire par contre une anticipation
une véritable stratégie
elle est indispensable aujourd'hui les
etats unis ont un plan stratégique qui
est totalement à efficient dans leur
vision du numérique mondiale la chine a
un plan stratégique extrêmement offensif
défraiement documenté extrêmement
pertinent avec une stratégie de
puissance pour stratégie de souveraineté
un marché qui fermait faut bien savoir
que la chine n'a pas d'économie de
marché et qui pratiquent le dumping
alors que l'union européenne aujourd'hui
elle est ouverte aux 80 c'est un marché
qui a été conçu dans une forme
d'absolutisme à une logique des
conditions favorables mystères marché
qui pourrait fonctionner si c'était un
marché fermé dès lors et de noir des
conditions favorables
ça marche quand tout le monde et
respecte donc il faudrait que le marché
sera fermé si on part sur ce principe là
sinon il faut que les entreprises
européennes elles des accès aux mêmes
nardo même forme j'aurais tendance à
dire aux mêmes ressources que les
entreprises étrangères
sinon vous avez vous n'avez aucune
chance de pouvoir percer et de pouvoir
surtout à avoir une économie à une
économie pérenne du numérique qui
concerne quand même ils risquent
d'impacter près de 50% des enfants d'ici
cinq ans en fait c'est juste le sujet
majeur
merci à tous les deux ali j art cyril
delmon d'avoir été
avec mon pour évoquer ce lancement
officiel de la 5g en france merci et
dans quelques instants rester avec nous
partirons aux états unis donald trump ne
reconnaît toujours pas sa défaite à la
présidentielle et limoges un responsable
de la sécurité des élections qui avaient
rejeté les accusations de fraude
électorale
et puis nous parlerons de la réduction
du nombre de soldats américains en
afghanistan et en irak promise par
donald trump elle sera effective en
janvier 2021
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend sable
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autorités assez
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens que
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose alors jean
francky
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire espace en direct puisque
on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30
soyez les bienvenus si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france en
pleine transition donald trump continue
de contester sa défaite à l'élection
présidentielle
il n'hésite pas non plus à limogés ce
qui ne s'aligne pas sur ses positions
après s'être séparé de marque espère le
secrétaire à la défense au début du mois
c'est au tour de chris creps directeur
de l'agencé de cyber sécurité et de la
sécurité des infrastructures d'être
licencié et la liste pourrait encore
s'allonger
emilie gogh h contredit jusque dans son
propre camp à la tête de l' agence
gouvernementale chargée de la sécurité
des élections
chris creps a déjà réfuté et plusieurs
fois l'idée de fraude massive lors de
l'élection présidentielle mais il ya
quelques jours un communiqué commun ne
passe pas inaperçu il est publié par
plusieurs agences gouvernementales dont
celle qu'il dirige
l'élection du 3 novembre a été la plus
sûre de l'histoire américaine
à l'heure actuelle partout dans le pays
les agents des services électoraux sont
en train d'examiner et de vérifier à
nouveau l'ensemble du processus
électoral avant d'en finaliser le
résultat un camouflet pour donald trump
à l'origine de la nomination de chris
creps à la tête de cette agence
ce dernier est licencié
la récente déclaration de crise krebs
sur la sécurité de l'élection de 2020
était très inexact dans le sens où il ya
eu des irrégularités des fraudes
massives
y compris des votes de personnes
décédées des observateurs qui ont été
empêchés d'entrer dans des bureaux de
vote des bugs d'urnes électroniques
donald trump n'en est pas à son premier
limogeage depuis l'annnonce de sa
défaite
le 9 novembre dernier marque espère
secrétaire à la défense est remercié en
toile de fond les manifestations du
mouvement black l'animateur au printemps
dernier après la mort de georges floyd
un afro américain tué par un policier
blanc lors de son arrestation marque
espère s'était opposé au déploiement de
militaires
pour réprimer les manifestations une
prise de position qui lui coûtera sa
place à la tête du pentagone selon axios
un site d'information américain qui
avait déjà anticipé le licenciement de
marques espèrent les prochains sur la
liste pourrait être lé directeur du fbi
et de la cia et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis houston avec
dave perkins analyse politique supporter
de donald trump
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir
dave perkins merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france quiz qui défend la
probité du scrutin limogé c'est le
dernier en date
bon c'est pas vraiment surprenant mais
pour vous le supporters de donald trump
passe quand même ça ne fait pas un petit
peu beaucoup de limoger tous ceux qui
sont finalement contre vous d'autant que
c'était un professionnel de la sécurité
monsieur creps je vais essayer de
remettre les choses en perspective creps
a apparemment fait un très bon travail
pour l'administration au cours des
quatre dernières années
mais voici c'est qu'il est arrivé où se
retrouver face à une réalité qui se
déroule devant nos yeux
donald trump s'apprête également à
porter plainte
c'est que le système de vote de guyenne
et à d'autres systèmes de contre
comptage des votes sont très faciles à
pirater et ont été inventés conçu pour
être facilement piraté et pour pouvoir
manipuler les résultats
la rancoeur de ces systèmes a fini lui
est là au venezuela a dit qu'il a avait
réussi à
ajouter un million de nouveaux votes
afin de s'assurer que maduro soirée lui
c'est ce même logiciel qui a été utilisé
dans beaucoup d'états des minutes des
comptes et aux états unis
l'idée qu'il soit facilement piratables
qu'il était utilisé afin de manipuler le
résultat d'élections que tout cela est
simple à faire je veux dire qu'il faut y
avoir une enquête car il y à des
irrégularités dans cette élection il ya
des moments lors du mardi de l'élection
où on voit la courbe des votes provider
augmenté de manière verticale et ce qui
a permis à jo hayden de prendre
l'aventage sur donald trump alors qu'il
n'avait pas auparavant
et c'est une impossibilité de
mathématiques c'est la preuve qu'il ya
eu de manipulation du logiciel du
système de comptage des votes afin de
changer les résultats dans des états qu
est ce qu on appelle les étapes qui voit
autant des villes telles que atlanta
détroit dans le michigan et à ces
informations existent il faut y avoir
des encriers des enquêtes et je pense
qu'une fois qu'il y aura des enquêtes on
va découvrir le pot-aux-roses et chris
ray a pris position a dit non tout va
bien rien de mal ne s'est passé
donnez moi de vous couper mais j'ai une
question quand même à vous posez vous
dites oui voilà c'est pas possible un
moment donné on a vu la courbe de joe
biden augmenté mais certains vous diront
que c'est aussi le fruit des votes par
correspondance vous savez bien que ces
votes ont été comptabilisés plus tôt à
la fin et que c'était souvent
traditionnellement plutôt pour joe biden
ces votes par correspondance vous le
dénier vous en tant que supporters de
donald trump vous n'êtes pas du tout
d'accord les votes par correspondance ne
sont pas responsables de ce coup
voici ce que cet ingénieur du venezuela
le décompte dans ces états étaient
interrompues à 20 jamais le découvrir là
était interrompu aussi en retard
la raison pour laquelle le compte était
interrompue et c'est la raison pour
laquelle donald trump à se tourner vers
les tribunaux
c'est que les personnes qui s'occupaient
du découlant j'avais découvert que les
formulaires dans la machine ne suffisait
pas pour renverser la majorité
pour donald trump donc ils ont dû
interrompre le décompte et relancer la
machine avec une nouvelle formule qu'il
aurait été transmis par internet
lorsqu'ils ont relancé le compte la
formule était bien plus rapide et à
avantager bien plus les démocrates c'est
pour cela qu'il ya ceux plus que ce
n'est pas à cause des votes par
correspondance ils n'ont pas été tous
comptent un moment le problème c'est que
les machines ont été modifiés afin qu'il
y ait plus de vote pour joe biden
proportionnellement à donald trump
il ya environ il ya environ cinq
millions de voix d'écart 5 millions de
voix d'écart dans cette élection est ce
que vous pensez qu'il ya eu autant de
fronde que ça même si on considère qu'il
peut y avoir eu des fraudes à ce
qu'elles sont aussi importantes que ça
selon vous si l'ingénieur qui a conçu ce
système peut créer un million de faux
suffrages
aux financières alors sans aucun doute
il peut en créer 5 millions aux états
unis
mais il le fallait à ces deux ouvertes
que pour remporter les grandes villas
dans les états pivots c'était leur cible
dès le départ le wiz consignes le
michigan la géorgie
et certains autres états qui ne pas
encore déterminer le vainqueur
mais ce système a été utilisé dans 30
états et le new york times ça a fait un
exposé qui vient exposer il ya des
années sur le danger de ce système on
voit un professionnel de l'informatique
expliqué un étudiant comment pirater
cette machine donc cette machine et ce
logiciel sont très faillible des
collectifs démocrates sont son plein il
y a plusieurs années il ya deux ans et
aujourd'hui soudainement sénat le
démocrate reste silencieux sur le sujet
parce que ils utilisent maintenant à
leur profit en tout cas ce que vous vous
dites évidemment c'est la thèse défendue
c'est normal puisque vous êtes supporter
républicain par donald trump
il l'a encore dit mercredi c'est une
élection truquée j'ai gagné aujourd'hui
clairement monsieur perkins qu'est ce
que vous attendez de la justice nous
fait confiance à la justice de votre
pays pour faire la clarté sur cette
élection puisque vous êtes convaincus
que votre poulain la remporter je pense
que cela va se retrouver devant la cour
suprême est assez rapidement mais nous
n'avons pas encore terminé de construire
notre cas car la fraude est très large
et notre cas audois ne doit pas avoir la
moindre faiblesse car sinon on se
servira de la moindre faille tour
invalidée tout le cas mais les
démocrates sont vraiment sur le chantier
de guerre ils pensent qu'ils ont déjà
gagné le job hayden se déclare président
élu les avaient pas vrai pour être
président lui soit il faut que l'autre
candidat reconnaît sa défaite où il faut
que le collège électoral
vous consacrez et cela n'est pas encore
arrivé donc joe biden
s'appelle le président élu pour
influencer l'opinion du peuple américain
pour leur faire croire qu'il a déjà
gagnée donc cela va se retrouver dans un
cour suprême et je suis persuadé que
c'est donald trump qui va remporter
cette affaire merci beaucoup d'évêques
perkins analyse politique et supporters
de donald trump merci d'avoir été avec
nous dans vu de l'extérieur ce soir
c'était une promesse justement de donald
trump les états unis vont réduire le
nombre de leurs soldats déployés en
afghanistan et en irak à partir du 15
janvier prochain annonce mardi du
nouveau secrétaire à la défense
américain par intérim christopher miller
une décision qui contente les talibans
sur place mais qui inquiète une partie
de la population est détaillé avec
solène gaudin après quatre ans d'attenté
deux mille militaires américains en
mission en afghanistan et 500 en irak
vont rentrer chez eux
date limite de départ le 15 janvier
prochain
seulement cinq jours avant l'investiture
du prochain président des états unis
une promesse de donald trump tenue in
extremis mais tous ne prendront pas le
chemin du retour
environ 2500 militaires américains
resteront dans chacun des deux pays
près de vingt ans après l'arrivée des
premiers contingents envoyés par
washington sur place la population
s'inquiète allemande va donc voilà ep
talibans vont intensifier la violence
dans le but de s'emparer d'un plus grand
pouvoir politique en afghanistan
dans ce pays sur une voie dangereuse
le retrait des troupes étrangères
d'afghanistan entraînera une escalade de
la violence des talibans dans tout le
pays et il fera également swap rire
davantage les familles les rendra
incapable à des ciels quittent
l'afghanistan la sécurité ce pourrait
être encore plus menacée et la nuit
pourrait atteindre davantage de ses
objectifs pas d'inquiétude pour le
porte-parole du conseil national de
sécurité afghan selon lui la
quasi-totalité des opérations militaires
sont déjà conduites par les forces
afghanes
de leurs côtés les talibans se disent
satisfaits selon leurs représentants
cette décision permettrait de mettre fin
à la guerre plus rapidement mais cette
annonce inquiète certains pays notamment
l'allemagne
nous sommes particulièrement préoccupés
parce que l'annoncent des états unis
pourrait signifier pour la poursuite des
pourparlers de paix en afghanistan sans
nécessité nous ne devrions pas créer
d'obstacles supplémentaires ce à quoi un
retrait hâtif de l'afghanistan conduire
et très certainement
autre crainte la résurgence des groupes
terroristes
les attentats du 11 septembre 2001 ont
été orchestrées par le groupe jihadiste
al qaïda à l'époque ils étaient basés en
afghanistan où l'avait accueilli les
talibans vingt ans de guerre s'en sont
suivis dans le pays selon le pentagone
en afghanistan et en irak
près de 7000 militaires américains sont
morts et plus de 52000 ont été blessés
depuis les premières offensives
militaires américaines
pour en parler nous sommes avec david
rigoulet roze rédacteur en chef revue
orient stratégique chercheur associé à
l'institut de recherches internationales
et stratégiques bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous la décision donc de
donald trump de retirer 1 2 mille
soldats d'afghanistan et 500 d'irak a
inquiété le secrétaire général de l'otan
qui craint que l'afghanistan devienne un
refuge pour les terroristes est ce que
clairement vous partagez cette hypothèse
oui c'est une déclaration assez
inhabituel de gestes solberg qui est en
général beaucoup plus discret mais là
c'est vrai que il met le doigt sur un
problème qui est une inquiétude inquiets
par rapport à la présence de la
coalition internationale en afghanistan
à douze mille hommes dont à peu près la
moitié des américains et donc le retrait
qui est annoncé par donald trump
effectivement est conforme à ses
promesses de campagne électorale de ce
point de vue là il est assez cohérent
mais s'inquiète beaucoup beaucoup de
monde y compris d'ailleurs dans son
propre camp puisque mitch mcconnell qui
est le chef de la majorité républicaine
au sénat lui même qui est un soutien
déclaré du président donald trump a dit
que ça le fait que les ce retrait des
troupes précipité pourrait être une
erreur et qu'il pourrait ravir faire
plaisir contenter les personnes qui
souhaitent du mal aux états unis donc on
voit bien qu'il ya quand même des
interrogations y compris dans le camp
républicain
même si c'est effectivement dans le
registre des promesses qui sont qui
doivent être tenus par de la truck et on
peut penser que la transition qui est
qui est en cours qui est difficile avec
la future administration jo maiden c'est
aussi une manière de pour le président
donald trump de familièrement on peut
dire savonner la planche du futur
président ça veut dire en gros qu'on
aurait fait tout ça pour ça toutes ces
années
deux soldats américains sur place pour
en arriver finalement voilà presque à
zéro un repaire de terroristes ben ce
pays alors on n'en est pas là encore les
effectivement la question est posée bon
les promesses de donald trump c'était de
mettre fin aux guerres sans fin
c'était là déclare halal la formule qui
l'employait régulièrement il ya de ce
point de vue là il ya une cohérence par
rapport à ses propos constants 1 puisque
il avait été amené à faire un seul
contre le malgré lui d'une certaine
manière
contre l'avis de ses propres mais dieter
et puisque son intuition le pousser au
contraire un retrait donc il va jusqu'au
bout de ce retrait en le précipitant et
on peut noter que le timing était c'est
intéressant parce qu'effectivement ces
cinq jours avant la passation de pouvoir
qui est prévue en janvier
donc c'est aussi une manière de préparer
un certain nombre de difficultés pour le
futur président joe biden
même si officiellement les les alliés
sont encore engagés mais il ya beaucoup
d'interrogations qui qui surgissent
aujourd'hui à partir du moment où ce
retrait est acté une bonne avancée en
selon les talibans c'est la réaction des
talibans après l'annnonce de cette
réduction du nombre de soldats
américains sur place ce qu'on doit
voilà sans m'inquiéter de cette réaction
des talibans qui sont pas vraiment
connus pour leur modération même si les
etats-unis négocient depuis plusieurs
années avec eux oui mais pas l est pas
surprenante parce que elle va donc d'une
certaine manière elle contente leurs
attentes
on peut rappeler que dans le cadre de
l'accord de février 2020 qui avaient été
engagées avec les doigts avec les
talibans il y avait il y avait la
perspective du retrait qui était
effectivement qui devait être effectif
d'ici à mai 2021
il est accélérée donc ça ne peut que les
contenter de ce point de vue là et les
met en position de force par rapport au
gouvernement kaboul même si ce dernier
considère que l'essentiel des activités
militaires étaient déjà de leur fait
mais enfin en tout cas il ya quand même
il y avait quand même toujours un appui
feu aérien qui est très très important
on l'a vu dans certaines opérations
récentes
donc il ya de la part du gouvernement de
kaboul il ya l'effort ne pas montrer son
inquiétude mais enfin elle est réelle et
on peut le comprendre parce qu'il ya une
accélération du calendrier qui n'est pas
en leur faveur
et qu'est-ce que ça voudra dire
concrètement pour la population afghane
sur place ce retrait américain
bah on sent on sent monter une
inquiétude un de beaucoup alors de la
population générale notamment de
certaines minorités comme et à zéro
puisque on peut rappeler que le 2
novembre dernier il ya eu encore une
attaque de dice qui était faite contre
l'université de kaboul
il ya une situation délétère qui prévaut
et même si les troupes américaines sont
plus visés puisque ça fait partie de
l'accord entre américains et est
aliments sont plus visés en tant que
tels les troupes gouvernementales sont
des cibles qui demeurent des cibles
militaires pour les talibans donc la
situation va être appelé stabiliser
d'ailleurs les négociations depuis
septembre sont un peu enlisé entre entre
les autorités de kaboul et les
représentants talibans
donc là on voit bien que le il ya un
télescopage entre le calendrier
politique américain et la réalité sur le
terrain qui dépend faveur situation
organes merci david
rigoulet roze rédacteur en chef revue
orient stratégique chercheurs
socialistes d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france dont dans le reste
de l'actualité en afrique
les combats se poursuivent dans la
région éthiopienne du tigre et le
gouvernement et les autorités locales
ont revendiqué chacun leur côté et
d'importantes victoires militaires après
deux semaines de combats
cette guerre provoque un afflux de
réfugiés au soudan voisin
l'onu se dit inquiète face à cette
nouvelle crise humanitaire françois
xavier lambert entouré d'autres réfugiés
cette femme s'effondre en larmes elle
vient d'apprendre le meurtre de sa mère
dont elle était sans nouvelles cette
scène de détresse est loin d'être isolé
parmi les milliers d'éthiopiens qui ont
quitté leur région d'origine le tigre et
tous ont fui pour échapper à l'horreur
des combats entre l'armée fédérale et
les forces locales désormais réunies
dans ce camp de fortune sous d'année
proche de la frontière
ils redoutent le sort réservé à leurs
proches restés chez eux des gens sont
tués par balle avec des couteaux des
épées nous nous sommes enfuis à travers
le désert jusqu'aux montagnes pour nous
cacher et aujourd'hui nous sommes venus
ici
nous venons juste d'arriver nous avons
payé un prix plus élevé que quoi que ce
soit pour venir ici
les réfugiés éthiopiens serait désormais
près de 36000 selon les autorités
soudanaises
face à la dégradation de la situation
l'onu redoute une crise humanitaire à
grande échelle
près de 4000 personnes franchir et
chaque jour la frontière entre les deux
pays
les routes menant à la région du tigré
reste bloqué et nos partenaires
avertissent que les provisions seront
bientôt épuisés exposant ainsi des
millions de personnes au risque
d'insécurité alimentaire et aux maladies
depuis le 4 novembre l'armée éthiopienne
a lancé une offensive d'ampleur dans
cette région du nord de l'ethiopie ou le
front de libération du peuple du tigré
défilent gouvernement depuis plusieurs
mois les forces gouvernementales
assurent être entrés dans la dernière
phase de leur opération
qui pouvait selon elle s'achevait dans
moins de deux semaines mais la version
diffère du côté des rebelles du tigre et
qui revendique également avoir remporté
de nombreuses batailles la réalité de la
situation sur le terrain reste difficile
à évaluer
les communications en temps parties
étaient coupées dans la région et des
restrictions de déplacement sont
imposées aux journalistes le conflit
touche également l'erythrée voisins dont
la capitale a été la cible de roquettes
le secrétaire d'état américain mike
pompéo a dénoncé une tentative des
autorités petit grain de déstabiliser la
région
les combats auraient déjà fait plusieurs
centaines de morts
ouais c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
dans quelques minutes pour 1 point
complet sur l'actualité de la journée
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte on soit vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vrai